[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about the top 10 ranked
Pro heroes in the world of boku no hero
and this is according to the brand new
official rankings that have just been
revealed in chapter 184 of the manga it
is important to remember that the hero
rankings are not based solely on brute
strength rather the rankings are based
on multiple factors such as how
effective each hero is at doing his or
her job how many cases they have
successfully resolved how much they
contribute to society what their
approval ratings are and so on before
this chapter we knew some of the top ten
heroes and their rankings but not all of
them for example at the start of the
story we know that Almighty is the
number one Pro hero and endeavor is the
number two pro hero but we did not know
who the number 3 pro hero was and this
question of who is the number 3 pro hero
has been popping up in the comments
sections of our videos constantly but
now in Chapter 184 we are introduced to
some brand new pro heroes for the very
first time and we finally have
confirmation of each of the top ten
heroes and their respective rankings in
this video I will list them all for you
from number 10 to number 1 and I will
also give you all the information that
we have so far about each hero and that
includes their quirks needless to say as
these are the latest rankings based on
information revealed in chapter 184 of
the manga this video will include manga
spoilers there is just no way around it
so you have been warned in the last
video I asked you guys to tell me who
your favorite anime villains of all time
are on Twitter and Instagram I am
working on that video idea right now but
in the meantime I'm gonna ask you guys
to let me know who your favorite heroes
are in anime this can include MHA or any
other anime and all you have to do is
follow us on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar and reply to the pinned
thread telling me who your favorite
anime heroes are and why your
responses will be relevant for a future
video and before we get started if you
enjoyed this type of content and you
want to see more be sure to leave a like
to let me know and if you happen to be
new to the channel don't forget to
subscribe and Texas smash that
notification valve and now let's get
into it at number 10 we have the dragon
hero Luke you when we first meet Luke
you as the pro hero who takes on to you
Rocco and Neri Hado to work in her hero
office she is the number nine ranked pro
hero but in the latest rankings she has
fallen to number 10 her quirk allows her
to turn into a dragon even though we
don't know too much about her quirk we
do know that in her dragon form the uq
becomes massive in size and extremely
powerful she is able to deal with very
strong villains on her own and without
much trouble she also has wings in her
dragon form so we can assume that she
can fly which is obviously an extremely
useful ability both in battle and for
other purposes
we don't know if this quirk has any
major limitations like for example or uq
only being able to use it for a few
minutes at a time or something like that
but nevertheless a pro hero who can
literally turn into a freaking dragon
definitely deserves to be in the top ten
at number nine we have the armored hero
yoru mo Chou this is a pro hero that we
never heard of before chapter 184 the
armored hero is an older man with a long
beard and as you might expect his hero
outfit appears to be armored reminiscent
of the armor that samurai warriors used
since he was just introduced and very
briefly we don't know much about this
hero other than the fact that he is
older and experienced and that at one
point he was ranked in the top three Pro
Heroes as his current ranking is
announced the armored hero complains
that his position has declined because
of the errors of the modern ranking
system we still haven't seen him use his
clerk but based on the fact that he was
once in the top three Pro heroes we can
assume that his quirk is quite powerful
the quirk is likely related to armor
perhaps he can manipulate his armor to
make it harder or to create weapons with
it or perhaps he can even manipulate an
entire
like steel or iron and maybe he used
that ability to create his own armor
being able to control steel would
definitely be an extremely strong and
useful quirk worthy of a top-10 hero at
number eight we have the laundry hero
wash another hero that we first meet in
chapter 1 84
washes hero costume looks literally like
a washing machine if you are wondering
how a washing machine made it to the
number 8 pro hero spot don't worry
you're not alone I guess we can assume
that despite his comical appearance wash
must be a strong hero with an extremely
strong quirk because ranking number 8
out of the thousands of Pro Heroes is no
joke we can also assume that washes
quirk is related to water maybe he can
manipulate water or generate water and
soap in order to form powerful bubbles
he may have the ability to produce a
strong jet of water and bubbles that he
can use to immobilize his opponents at
this point it is all just speculation
but I'm extremely curious to see the
laundry hero in action by the way let me
know down in the comments how you think
that this heroes quirk might work and
what is your opinion about the laundry
hero at number 7 we have calmly woods
calmly woods is a hero that we have met
before and in fact we first get to see
him in action way back in the very first
chapter of the manga and episode 1 of
the anime Kamui's real name is Shinji
Nisha but we've never seen him outside
of his good inspired hero costume so we
don't know what he actually looks like
the name of his quirk is Arbour
sometimes called lumber its type is
emitter and it works at long range
his quirk enables calmly to produce tree
roots from his body and to use them as
weapons against his opponents he can use
his quirk to create a special attack
known as lacquered chains prison which
traps opponents inside a makeshift
wooden cage this can be a very effective
technique for Heroes as it allows calm
weed to confine multiple opponents at
once and he uses this technique on
several members of the League of
villains during the hideout raid arc due
to the wood based nature of his core
his power is not effective against fire
based quirks according to media gossip
calmly woods is rumored to be in a
relationship with Mount Lady at number
six we have the shield hero crust
another brand-new hero as far as we are
concerned
crust is a young man who is shown to be
genuinely upset about the fact that all
might was forced to retire as the number
one pro hero and if you just heard that
and you're confused about the fact that
all might retired you must have missed
my spoiler warning at the beginning of
this video because this video does
contain manga spoilers of course because
of his emotional reaction we can assume
that just like for Deku all might was a
big inspiration for the shield hero
crust as well based on his hero name we
can assume that crust can produce a hard
substance from his body that he can use
as a shield and potentially as an
offensive weapon his quirk might just be
the type of hardening power that
Kirishima and Tetsu Tetsu have or it
might have another aspect to it but we
just don't know at this time at number 5
we have the rabbit hero miracle ladies
and gentlemen it looks like we have a
new hero waifu alert miracle is also a
hero that we meet for the first time in
chapter 184 and she is an extremely
physically fit woman with rabbit ears
long hair and a crescent moon symbol on
her chest miracle is currently the
highest ranked female pro hero and she
appears to be fiercely independent she
openly mocks heroes who join a hero team
because she thinks that joining a team
is for weaklings again we don't know how
her quirk works at this time but we can
reasonably assume that it is related to
the abilities of a rabbit as we know
rabbits are extremely fast agile and
they can hop so medicos quirk may allow
her to use extreme speed to hop great
distances and to move with incredible
agility at number four we have the ninja
hero headshot formerly the number 5 pro
hero
Shinya kami Hara or headshot is now
ranked at number 4 and he has an
appearance that resembles a ninja we've
actually known add shot for a while as
he played an important role
during the hideout raid argh the name of
his quirk is Fulda body it's type is
transformation and it works at close
range
his quirk enables headshot to fold and
stretch his body which gives him great
stealth and agility on top of that due
to intense ninja training headshot is
able to transform his body faster than
the speed of sound and he is even able
to twist and turn his own elastic body
into a sharp weapon that he can use
against his opponents headshot is a
great example of a hero who has a great
quirk but also spent years training hard
to unlock the quirks full potential at
number 3 the fiber hero best genus
formerly the number four ranked pro hero
his real name is suna goo hakimoto but
he is better known by his alias best
genus not beast genus by the way some
people seem to think that best genus he
got that name because he was the winner
of the best genus Award for eight years
in a row believe it or not the best
genus Award is 100% real in Japan and it
is given to celebrities who look the
best in genes it is actually one of the
most prestigious fashion Awards in Japan
since best genus is a fashion icon in
the world of boku no hero and he is
known for his love of denim all those
awards make perfect sense it is
important to mention that on top of
being a fashion icon best genus is also
a very strong and brave Pro hero the
name of his quirk is fiber master it's
type is emitter and it works at medium
range this quirk enables best genus to
manipulate textile material he can use
strings of fabric from clothing as
weapons both offensive and defensive and
he can also use fabric to restrain and
immobilize opponents he scores a perfect
5 out of 5 in technique and is known as
a fiercely tough fighter at number 2 we
have the winged hero Hawks swooping into
second place Hawks is a stylish Lee
dressed hero with a pair of large wings
on his back as the blurb describing him
in the manga states he claims to take it
easy but he is actually quite ferocious
we know that class 1 ace
student talk Liam II interned under
hawks and it is possible that Hawks was
the mysterious number three ranked pro
hero before all might retired and so
naturally if that was the case he would
now be ranked at number two we know that
endeavor was second before all might
retire meant we knew that best genus was
fourth and headshot was fifth so
assuming that the old number three pro
hero did not drop off drastically and
Hawks took his place it is likely that
endeavor Hawks best genus and Ed shot
all just moved up one spot because of
all mites retirement again being a newly
introduced character we don't know much
about Hawks at this time although we can
assume that he can use his bird-like
wings to fly maybe even create wind
gusts and so on we can also assume that
his high rank means that Hawks is
extremely able and effective as a hero
overall and at number one the number one
pro hero is the flame hero endeavor
formerly the number two pro hero and
ever AKA ng Todoroki finally succeeds at
becoming number one only after all mites
retirement which is of course something
that bothers him since he always wanted
to get to number one by being better
than all might not by default even
though he is an extremely successful
hero and has a higher rate of result
cases than any other hero endeavor is
also notorious for mistreating his wife
and children including class one a
student shot Todoroki throughout his
life and ever was driven by a jealousy
of all might and by the ambition to
become stronger or to raise a child that
would become stronger than all might the
name of his Quercus hell flame its type
is emitter and it works at medium range
as a result of his quirk endeavour is
able to generate and manipulate flames
which makes for a powerful weapon
against all potential opponents the
quirt can be deactivated if endeavor
wishes it but he is almost always seen
with flames around his body which speaks
to his vanity and a desire to stand out
at all times and ever can control the
temperature of his flames and make them
so hot that they become blue
at which point he can obliterate
everything in sight on a cellular level
on top of that he can even walk on walls
by heating up the soles of his feet to
such an extent that they partially
melted the wall and stick to it
and ever is in general a stacked hero as
he scores a 5 out of 5 and powers speed
and technique with a 4 out of 5 and
intelligence but only a 2 out of 5 in
cooperativeness and that is it for the
first time we have official confirmation
of the current top 10 ranked pro heroes
in the world of boku no hero I hope you
guys enjoyed this video I hope you found
it helpful and if you want to tell me
who your favorite anime heroes are be
sure to follow us on Twitter and
Instagram at anime up roar and reply to
the thread if you did like this video
you can leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new don't forget to
subscribe and Texas smash that
notification valve a big thank you to
soul maka for alerting me as soon as the
new chapter with the rankings came out
and of course thank you to my brother
goes in for helping out with the editing
as usual as always thank you all so much
for watching a lot more boku no hero
content is coming soon and until next
time see us bass cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]